I think the most difficult part of
cleaning an iPhone is just knowing that
you're touching somebody else's Grime
and milk it's disgusting really when you
think about it
I can already see that we've got quite a
lot of gunk in the ear speaker and the
speaker grills themselves so hopefully
there'll be some gunk in there to see
and we can give it a real good clean out
as well
lint builds up from inside somebody's
pocket and over time when the charging
cables inserted taken out reinserted all
that happens is it just compacts into
the charge port itself and leaves this
sort of mess behind and all this lint
over time it just compacts every time
you put it on charge it just compacts
deep down into the port
when you start noticing the ear speaker
becomes quiet the microphone people
can't hear you or it's not charging
correctly you might have to stand on
your head and do a backflip just to make
it charge
that's probably when you need to start
thinking about cleaning out that charge
port or the air speaker
I'm using this little BGA scraper which
is typically designed for scraping the
resin overfill or underfill from logic
boards but it doubles up as a really
really useful tool for cleaning out
these charging ports
[Music]
the stuff what we usually find in the
charging ports and crevices of the phone
is mostly I have a pocket gun all Club
from the bottom of handbags I mean I'm
not a forensic scientist but I'm gonna
guess this dog as
dust hello I I don't really know how to
describe the uh
the five as well in there all the things
that we found in the phone rice is quite
common when phones have become water
damaged because they'll stick the phone
in rice that doesn't work by the way we
did find some weed in one of them and it
looked like they must have been keeping
the stash in their pocket and it the
same thing again there was weed inside
the charge port
so this iPhone 7 is coming for a battery
replacement and you as you can see it's
absolutely full of dust lint hair wood
chip feathers you name it it's in this
phone well I can see that the screen's
been replaced before I think they've
probably just never replaced the dust
seal what's on there
this is really common because believe it
or not not many repair places will
replace that dust and moisture seal it's
the best way to clean something like
this out is to get all the
thick stuff probably with the dust
blower
there is definitely a risk that this
dual should cause a short circuit on the
on the motherboard it's going to put
lots of strain on peripheral Hardware
like the loudspeaker is going to be
quiet the vibration mode is not going to
work very well or you're going to get
funny sounds from the vibration motor a
lot of people think that it's just for
moisture it keeps a seal between the
screen and the chassis of the phone
which out of the factory is designed so
that it's sealed away from elements like
dust and dirt
speaker cleaning is one of the things
what we get all the time where
somebody's phone is really quiet
10 to 20 of the phones what we get in
actually need cleaning out
the easiest way to clean out a iPhone
ear speaker is using some isopropyl
alcohol the customer lasts for a ear
speaker replacing but in reality it just
needs cleaning out and even if we did
replace the ear speaker it probably
would still be quiet because that mesh
is just bummed up and gunked up then we
loosen up the gunk with a toothbrush
make sure that it's not the toothbrush
that you've used this morning to brush
your teeth and then we play this sound
which plays a 165 Hertz sound which acts
as a sort of ultrasonic cleaner
for the most part I think that the most
common thing that gets in here speaker
is probably earwax
I don't really want to think about what
else it could be what's getting in there
because it's yeah it's gross
[Music]
we use two different types of brushes
for the softer brush we use a toothbrush
and then a slightly more stiff one is
this small horsehair brush
the vibrations act as an agitator and it
loosens the dirt what's in those tiny
little gaps in the ear speaker
[Music]
so the cloth over the speaker we add a
little bit of alcohol onto there and the
way that that works is just adding a
finer layer of cleaning stuff just to
get any remaining bits of dust out of
there
[Music]
so for this one it's a iPhone 11 Pro and
it's got a little bit of gunk in the
speaker Grille at the bottom which would
make the phone pretty quiet this is very
similar to what gets built up inside the
charge port it's just pocket Gunk the
best tool for this one is the shop
pointed BGA scraper again
the debris in these holes will often
look like a brownie sort of beige color
whereas the actual speakers are black so
you'll know that you've got it in there
foreign
got involved with fixing friends and
Family's phones sorting up technical
problems for them and once I started
learning about phone repair and just got
deeper and deeper into it it's like a
rabbit holder I just got fully subbed
down it
we received about 20 iPhones per week in
the post and we probably
taken from walking customers between 5
and 15 phones a day
you get lots of instances where somebody
might bring a phone in and it might be a
minor thing and they say oh look my
phone's completely dead and it's it's
really good to see people very happy
once you've repaired their devices
[Music]
the the build up inside the charge port
usually occurs when it's been placed
into your
current State anymore right